minister lovely to have you in this
morning well thank you for having me
eye-catching announcement to put it
mildly a fifth of the civil service to
go explain just in practical terms how
and when this is going to happen
well i know it sounds eye-catching but
it's just getting back to the civil
service that we had in 2016 after
francis moore had done the job that i
now do
and bear in mind since then we've taken
on
extra people for specific tasks so
dealing with the aftermath of brexit and
dealing with kovid so there's been a
reason for the increase but now we're
trying to get back to normal um how can
this be done well about up to 38 000
people a year leave the civil service so
the simplest way to do it is to have a
freeze on recruitment which we've done
in the cabinet office but but you can't
control where those redundancies come
from and that's you're quite right to
mention that because that's a really
important part of this is that we need
to have with the reductions a very
effective learning and development
programme so that civil servants
whose roles may not be the optimal use
of their time can be trained so that
they can fulfill other roles within the
civil service you're the minister
responsible so you will have an idea
already i'm sure
so where exactly will the bulk of these
cuts come which are the most inefficient
government departments well and arms
length bodies because this includes um
the quankos and
what i've seen within the cabinet office
which is where i work and bear in mind
each sector of state will be responsible
for his or her own department um is that
there is duplication within government
so that you have a communications
department
and then you have within another
department some people doing
communications so it's trying to ensure
that
you use the resource that you've got
rather than duplicating it bit by bit
and therefore there are many savings
that come from that and then you have to
ensure that people are being used as
efficiently as possible to do the roles
that are necessary but bear in mind we
took on 91 000 extra actually we took on
more than that um at the peak uh to
implement cavind and brexit
but to be absolutely clear about this i
mean
why isn't this being described as a
return to austerity because that is what
it is isn't it significant cuts to
departmental budgets significant cuts to
deep to departmental staffing levels
it's austerity by another name i don't
think it is because
what is being done is getting back to
the efficiency levels we had in 2016.
that's a perfectly reasonable and
sensible the job's done with
um ambition
uh the the administration the
negotiations most of the work in
relation to brexit has been completed
tell that to northern ireland
that's important work but that's not the
same as working out uh how our um laws
have evolved and things like that so the
detailed administrative work that has
primarily been done but well over half
of all civil servants working job
centres prisoners for hmrc
you're not telling me that they're being
inefficient in those departments are you
no no i'm not and so will depend
department by department as to what
roles are needed but there will be
efficiencies that you can get in some
departments through increased automation
increased use of technology which is
something that all sensible businesses
will be doing but as the institute for
government points out that anyone who
suggests that all of this can come
through natural wasted is wrong there
will have to be targeted redundancies in
parts of the civil service that's not
necessarily accurate um that as i say up
to 38 000 people go every year so you're
talking about a little bit over two
years of natural wastage now you rightly
pointed out they won't all necessarily
go in exactly the area that you want
them to go but then within the pool
you've got you will be able to retrain
people so this is all just ideological
isn't it i mean rather we understand the
conservative desire to see a smaller
state you're certainly not talking as i
understand it you're one of those voices
around the cabinet table disagreeing
with potentially a windfall tax on the
energy companies well the only bit that
is ideological is that we should spend
taxpayers money properly and not
wastefully
now you make quite i mean
you may call that ideologically i think
that's absolutely suggesting targeting
the public rather than the private
sector is ideal but do you think that
any of your viewers thinks we should
waste taxpayers money and employ people
we don't that's right that's a farcical
question it's not actually because you
are saying of course this is purely
ideological when it's about efficiency
it's about doing things properly it's
about governing effectively and
recognizing that every penny we take in
tax has to come off the backs of people
working hard you've been in power since
2010 if there's inefficiency in the
civil service it's down to you someone
else might have been wearing the rosette
but it was the same color as that but
what i'm saying is we're getting back to
the 2016 levels which we got to through
a major efficiency and drive but there
were good reasons for taking on extra
people yeah brexit brexit meant brexit
cost us money and then we had to hire
some services those reasons have passed
but brexit meant that we had to hire
more civil servants the brexit
opportunity
when the expansion when the extra people
were primarily employed 2016. boris
johnson was not the prime minister and
it could have been done very differently
as i say someone else was wearing the
rosette back then i mean
you've been asking people to come back
and work in in whitehall i know that's
something you that has exercised you is
there perhaps the suggestion that those
people who are unwilling to return to
the office could be culled as part of
this 90 000 figure no there is a place
for working from home and there is a
place for hybrid working
but we've seen in the passport office in
dvla where dvla had a strike as well
which made things worse that public
services to some people have not been
delivered because of working from home
and we've now had the fda the telegraph
is a brilliant story saying the fda
thinks people should be able to live
abroad and work for civil service i mean
i i didn't think that i mean the flip
side of that coin is i mean you think
that services are going to be delivered
with fewer people within the civil
service yes i do because we as i've said
we've
dealt with some of the issues that led
to the increase in numbers and we can
become
more efficient uh i'm not sure if the
fda was actually calling for offshoring
i'd be very surprised if they wanted
british jobs to go overseas it seems
rather bold and unlikely uh called by a
left-wing union i think i think on on
that point many will agree with you um
can we talk just just briefly about
what's been going on in and around
downing street can you give us a running
total of exactly how many fixed penalty
notices have now been have now been
handed out but i generally suggest that
if you're looking to cut the civil
servants you might sack everyone who's
received an fpn but that presumably be
quite embarrassing for the prime
minister
um you'll have to ask the metropolitan
please how many um fixed penalty notes
they've issued that's a matter for that
you could have asked dining street
surely before coming in this morning
well i read in the papers yesterday it
was 100 but that's what i've seen in the
newspapers okay but this is routine
reporting for you sure indeed just just
can we move on to cost of the cost of
living crisis because quite clearly it
is it is a major priority for this
government it would be a major priority
for any government of course in what
ways are you experiencing the cost of
living crisis right now
the cause of living crisis is affecting
my constituents very significantly i'm
actually you
i'm not going to talk about me
personally my personality i've asked the
question i know you have and i'm not
going to answer it because my personal
circumstances are very fortunate and i
think my lecturing people on my own
circumstances is not relevant not
helpful
but i do try and help constituents who
get in touch with me and what help can a
member of parliament give to try and
encourage constituents to claim benefits
that they are entitled to to make the
most opportunity to seek the resources
that are there for instance there's a
billion pounds that local authorities
have to distribute to people who are in
particular need and therefore to try and
help my constituents who are struggling
and i'm very well aware through my pace
bag and through surgeries of how
difficult people are finding it i
understand that you're aware of it but
can you genuinely empathize with someone
who is known about let me finish can you
genuinely empathize with someone who is
making a choice about whether or not to
feed themselves or to keep themselves
the reason i ask and you will understand
this is that people do sometimes look at
you
three-piece suits they're kind of the
affectations the nanny the westminster
town house the manor house in the
countryside the personal wealth you know
running perhaps into triple figure
millions that's simply not true
okay but that is that is the perception
and did they look at you and say how on
earth can this person empathize with me
he's never experienced anything like it
and that's a very fair question but one
of the great strengths of our political
system is it as a constituency mp you
have people come to see you
most weeks to discuss how they are
living their lives and you would have to
be the most stone-hearted person not to
be able to empathize when people come to
talk to you about how they are living
and what they haven't got the same lived
experience if you genuinely haven't been
clearly because you can't i don't afford
to
again i i ask this because we heard a
little earlier in the week from your
colleague lee anderson saying saying
something in the comments that grabs a
lot of attention wonder we can just play
it to our viewers now
there's not this dude this this massive
use for food banks in this country we've
got generation after generation who
cannot cook properly they can't cook a
meal from scratch they cannot budget the
challenge is there
what did you make of those comments
somebody in my position cannot possibly
say things like that i can't cook myself
and it wouldn't be right for me to
lecture people on how to live their
lives is it right for the anderson
election people what i would like to say
i i want to answer the
long introductory comments that you made
because i think human nature is about
empathizing with people who live
different lives from oneself i think
that's the whole point of humanity
actually is that you understand the
issues the difficulties that people face
without having to do it for yourself
because i've referred to you to me as
the as the honorable member for the 18th
century
and that's great um but
human nature is understanding other
people's lives but it's also worth
bearing in mind that nobody leads
anybody else's life
and therefore this idea that there is a
category of people who automatically
understand how other people that live
and another set who don't is simply not
true all of which is a really
long-winded way of avoiding answering
the question you know should should lee
anderson have lectured people on not
being able to provide meals for their
children at 30 pounds a day
i would not have said it
fair enough
on the northern ireland protocol
when the prime minister described a deal
as being oven ready to what was he
referring
he was referring to a means of leaving
the european union and that the fact
that the agreement itself
provides for the updating of the
northern ireland protocol
that's in the text that it will be
updated to be made more efficient and
more seamless and that hasn't worked
that hasn't happened the eu has not
delivered that but when he described as
oven ready the deal he was talking about
the withdrawal agreement which included
the protocol and the private call
included the mechanism for its updating
what is northern what what is taking
place right now that was not predicted
by businesses on both sides of the irish
sea the updating that was provided for
within the agreement has not happened
properly well that that that wall down
the roc that border down the irish sea
which we were told would never happen
was generated by a northern ireland
protocol that your government came up
with and your government in fact in fact
you were directly involved in reducing
the amount of time it had for mps to
debate it but bear in mind that there
was um an implementation period
and there was a suspension of elements
of the
protocol and that that allowed time had
there been good faith on the side of the
european union to
provide the update that the agreement
itself expected to take place it just
doesn't strike me as oven ready if you
have to go back to the drawing board or
yeah i do i it's passed itself back to
the unfit for human rights you're
ignoring the well
now um if we're going to go for sell by
dates everything has an ultimate sell-by
date that's not quite the point the
point is that the agreement itself
provided for its updating and that
updating has not happened because the eu
has not been willing uh to negotiate in
good faith
is it legal to change the protocol you
know actually as we're intending to do
um we will there are provisions within
the treaty for unilateral uh changes to
the protocol as we discovered with the
eu it was the eu who invoked article 16
itself in relation to vaccines um during
the pandemic i wonder if we can just
return to where we started and cuts to
the cuts to the civil service how many
advisors did you arrive with this
morning because it looked like more than
two
three four yes they don't all work
directly for me they work within the um
cabinet office to work within the
cabinet office and two of my special
advisors
do you perhaps detect an opportunity for
some efficiency savings there um i cover
a very wide area of public policy but
there should be efficiency throughout
the civil service
one final question and it's it's not a
topic that i think a lot of people are
are desperately concerned about
afghanistan why did the government not
release the information
that the house of commons had compelled
to do so
well i think the government actually has
provided more information than it's
constitutionally obliged to do
if you look at the first edition of us
in may it says that a humble address
falls at a prorogation
now admittedly by the time you get to
the 12th or 13th edition which about 50
years later erskine may says a humble
dress doesn't fall at a prerogation
but by that time humble addresses had
ceased to be part of the house of
commons routine activity why have we not
published the intelligence and the the
intelligence warning about guinea
leverage
so isn't it simple fact we know why it
hasn't been we know that has been
published because the security services
said perhaps it's not the brightest of
ideas to make the son of a former kgb
spy who who himself was a media ban you
know a member of the upper hand did you
look at lord views evidence to
the committee that looked into this yes
he said that there was no improper
pressure brought to bear on him that
everything was handled in the normal way
that seemed to be a pretty pretty
convincing answer but genuinely why have
we not had to have not had that evidence
why would we not have that
the government has actually done more
than it was constitutionally obliged to
do just one final point this is just
breaking news i understand we've kind of
been we are delaying you here but this
is something that you you have a view on
uh jeffrey donaldson uh dep leader has
said pretty much pretty clearly his
party is not going to be supporting the
election of a new speaker in storming
today
what hope is there for storming right
now
um well i think sir jeffrey's position
has been relatively clear that
he believes the protocol is not
functioning properly and needs reform i
agree with sir jeffrey i think that's a
reasonable position understandable
position of him to take we cannot allow
the functioning of the european union to
undermine the united kingdom